SILVANO LUCIANI:
Hi, everybody.
Welcome to Google+ Sign-In
for iOS developers.
I'm Silvano Luciani, and I'm a
Developer Programs Engineer
for the Google+ platform.
XIANGTIAN DAI: I'm Xiangtian
Dai, and I'm a software
engineer for Google+
iOS platform.
I'm not a native English
speaker, so I have been
rehearsing this talk many, many
times to make it crystal
clear to you.
SILVANO LUCIANI: And I'm
Italian, so I might say things
with a funny accent.
Please forgive me.
So in the next half an hour,
what we want to show you is
what you can get by integrating
Google+ Sign-In in
your iOS app.
We will start with the basic
Google+ Sign-In, get users to
sign into your app.
We will show you two
ways of sharing--
an active way of sharing,
interactive posts, and a
passive way of sharing,
app activities.
And in the end, we will tell you
something about sign out
and disconnect, which are two
requirements that we ask you
to implement if you want
to integrate Google+
Sign-In in your app.
We will show you examples from
some of our partners, and then
we will show you the steps to
integrate this functionality
in your XCode project.
We will show a lot of
resources and URLs.
Don't worry if you don't
get those URLs down.
These slides will
be public soon.
The talk is being recorded.
It will be public.
You can get back to it later
with more [? calm. ?]
But let's start trying to
understand why do you want to
integrate Google+ Sign-In
in your app.
So the first thing, the very
basic thing that you get, is
login from a trusted provider.
Google is well-known to be safe,
especially when it comes
to authentication.
For example, we have two-step
verification, which is very
effective against account
hijacking.
Once you get the very basics,
once you get the user to sign
in to your app using their
Google+ profile, you get back
the possibility of customizing
your app, using information
from their profile and using
information that you can get
from the Google+ social graph,
which means making the
experience for every
user more personal.
But you can also get the
possibility of engage, having
users from your app engage with
their friends on Google+.
This means interactive posts,
content shared from your app
with an action that will drive
engagement and adoption back
to your app.
And app activities, which means
activities that the
users are doing on your app
written to Google and surfaced
in many different ways.
As I mentioned, that's adoptions
back to your app.
So let's start from
the very basic--
Google+ Sign-In.
I will use one of our partners
as an example--
Banjo.
They were here in the
Sandbox today.
If you don't know them, it's a
social discovery app that can
aggregate information from
different social networks and
show that info based
on your location.
So when you want to start using
Banjo, first thing, you
need to sign up to
one of the social
networks that they support.
And you can see a red
button, Google.
You can sign in with
Google to Banjo.
When you click the Sign-In, the
first thing that you will
see is our consent dialogue.
We designed this consent
dialogue very carefully with
one thing in mind-- the user.
Users want to have control
over certain things.
And one of the most important
things for the users is
controlling which of their
friends will be
shared with an app.
Which is why, as you can see
in the first line of the
consent dialogue, they can
click, "edit list," and they
can edit, add or subtract
circles from the circles that
will be shared with your app.
This doesn't mean that we are
sending your app information
about the circles.
We will send the users that are
contained in those circles
as a flat list.
There's another line, which
is very important,
is the third line.
Users care about what will
be visible to whom in the
activities that they
do on your app.
We will get back to that line
later when talking about app
activities.
So once I'm signed in to Banjo,
it's already different.
I have my profile picture
on the top-right corner.
And this is the very basic
personalization
that you can do.
There's a lot more that you can
do by getting data from
our public data API.
You can also get the list of
friends, a list of my friends,
that are already using this app,
which means that I can
start my experience with Banjo
not from scratch, not from
nothing, but interacting with
some of the friends that I
already have.
To get started in integrating
Google+ Sign-In in your
project, the first thing that
you will need to do is go to
the Google API Console.
The Google API Console is a tool
that will allow you to
manage access to all
the Google APIs
for all your project.
The first thing, you will need
to create a project.
The second thing, you will need
to create an OAuth 2.0
Client ID, which will allow
us to track the
usage of every API.
In your case, this will be a
client ID for an installed
application of type iOS.
Now, you can find detailed stats
of this procedure on our
developer documentation.
One thing that I want to point
out is three parameters which
are very specific for
your iOS app.
The first one is the
bundle ID, which is
identifying your app.
You will configure this later in
the XCode project as well.
And we will see why it's
important, because it's the
way your app will handle the
data that is coming back from
the authentication.
The second parameter is
the App Store ID.
That's the ID of your app
on the App Store.
And it's very important, because
in some cases users
might try to interact with your
app without having the
app installed on their
iOS device.
If we have this correctly
configured, it means that we
can redirect the user to the App
Store ID, to the page of
your app, have them install your
app, and then using deep
linking, they can go back in
the same context what they
were trying to interact
with your app.
Now, I've just mentioned
deep linking.
How many of you know what
deep linking is?
Ah, good number, good number.
Good job.
So the third thing that
you can do here
is enable deep linking.
And deep linking will allow
you to specify strings.
The format is up to you.
You can determine whatever
format is better for your app.
And this will allow you to bring
the user in the exact
context where they wanted to
interact with your app, which
could be a specific view
where they can
perform a specific action.
And we will see more
about this later.
XIANGTIAN DAI: Now you have
registered your app in Google
APIs Console, it is time to
download Google+ iOS SDK.
You download it from
developers.googl
e.com/+/mobile/ios.
And also, check out our online
references there.
Now that you have downloaded
Google iOS SDK, there are four
steps to set up your XCode
configuration for your
application target.
The first step is to drag the
following items from Google+
iOS SDK to your project--
GooglePlus.framework,
GoogleOpenSource.framework,
and then GooglePlus.bundle.
GooglePlus.framework contains
header files and libraries for
the Google+ iOS SDK.
GoogleOpenSource.framework
contains open source files
provided by Google that
is used in this SDK.
However, if you're already
using some of these open
source files, do not
include .framework.
Instead, include individual
files under the open source
directory of the SDK.
Only include these files you are
not already using so that
you do not end up with
duplicate symbols.
GooglePlus.bundle contains
images and strings used by the
Google+ Sign-In button.
Step two.
On the info tab,
add a URL type.
Use your bundle ID for both the
identifier and the URL scheme.
You must use the same bundle ID
that matches what you have
registered in Google
APIs Console.
This is how your app gets data
from authentication, sharing,
and deep linking.
Step three, build
Settings tab.
Find other linker flags, and
add dash Objective C. This
linker flag is needed for
libraries with Objective C
categories to link properly.
And step four, build
Phases tab.
In section, add binary to
libraries and the following
frameworks--
Security.framework and the
SystemConfiguration.framework.
These frameworks are needed
for the Google+ iOS SDK.
Now let's go with
some code setup.
First, you need to import
GooglePlus.h and
GoogleOpenSource.h.
You can import them in
individual .m files as needed,
or you can also import them in
your precompiled header file.
Second, you need to initialize
a client ID property of the
GPPSignIn instance before
using this object.
This client ID identifies your
app to Google services.
You get this client ID string by
registering your app in the
Google APIs Console.
If your app requires more
permissions from the user, in
addition to what the default
plus.login scope provides, you
need also to declare this list
of scopes and do this
initialization before using this
Google+ Sign-In object.
Now, adding a Sign-In button
to your app is very easy.
All you have to do is to drag a
button to your storyboard or
XIB file and set its custom
class to GPPSignInButton.
And don't forget to remove
the default label.
The SDK will handle the
appearance of the button.
You can also customize its style
and the color scheme to
match your app's
look and feel.
If you want, you can also draw
your own button, as long as it
meets our branding guidelines
at this location.
Now, if you draw your own
button, don't forget to call
Authenticate method on the
GPPSignIn instance.
This starts authentication
flow when
user taps on the button.
To complete the authentication
flow, you
need to do two things.
First, in your AppDelegate, let
GPPURLHandler handle the
incoming URL.
Second, one of your classes
must implement the
GPPSignInDelegate protocol,
for example, your relevant
ViewController class.
And you need to assign an
instance of this class as a
delegate to the GPPSignIn
object.
In this class, you implement
a method called
finishedWithAuth.
This method will be
called when the
authentication flow completes.
As a side note, when user
finishes signing in, we save
user's credentials in the
user's private keychain.
This is so that the user does
not need to type in their
password again when your
app starts next time.
In order to make use of
this feature, call
trySilentAuthentication.
There are two tips I
would like to offer
for the Sign-In flow.
First, user will be directed
to another
app to compete sign-in.
So that user will type into the
username and password in
another app.
This means your app will
go into the background.
Do not assume that your app,
when user has already signed
in, when your app comes back
to the foreground.
User could have declined to sign
in, or they could simply
use this Home button to switch
back to your app.
Instead, using the programming
interface that we just
discussed to get a notification
that the user has
finished signing in.
Second, to provide the user
with a single sign-in
experience we always prefer
to use the Google+ app, if
installed, to handle the
user signing in.
If this is not the behavior
you want, that's fine.
Simply set the attemptSSO
property of the GPPSignIn
object to "no." This way, the
SDK will always switch to
browser to handle
user's sign in.
Now user has signed in, let's
say we want to get the user's
profile image and their
display name.
To do that, we use
three objects--
a service, a query, and
a completion handler.
The service object identifies
which Google
service you're accessing.
In our case, it's the Google+
service, which you should have
enabled in Google APIs Console
for your project.
We get this object by calling
PlusService method on the
GPPSignIn instance.
A query is a request you send
to this Google service.
In our case, it's the query to
get the people's profile.
And then we get this
object by calling
queryForPeopleGetWithUserId
method, with the argument
"me." This special string
represents the current user.
And the completion handler is a
block that gets called when
the request comes back.
In our case, we're expecting
a GTLPlusPerson object.
This object contains information
about the user.
Both users' profile image and
their display name can be
retrieved from this topic
as its properties.
Finally, execute the query on
the Plus service with the
completion handler, and don't
forget to check for errors
inside the completion handler.
SILVANO LUCIANI: So now that you
have the users, it's time
to engage with their friends.
And the way to do this is
use interactive posts.
And I will use the Fancy
as an example.
The Fancy is another partner.
They were in our Sandbox
yesterday.
If you don't know them, it's an
app where people curate a
list of items, places, and
you can fancy items if
you like the items.
You can buy items, add
them to at list, or
just share with friends.
This is an example of
things that you
can find on the Fancy.
A very fancy watch, I have
to admit, on the bottom.
And the USB Hub House, which
is one of my favorites.
But I decide to focus
on this article.
Summer is coming.
I think that a hanging cliff
cabana, it's something that
you want to have.
And for $700, it's
a real deal.
So let's say I want to share
it with my friends.
On the top-right corner,
I have the Share icon.
When I click the Share icon,
I can see Google+
is one of the options.
When I click on Google+, I can
see the Share box for an
interactive post.
Looks like your average Share
box, but it's not.
I'm sharing, I'm adding some
text, saying this is really
handy for the summer.
You can see in the center
what I'm sharing.
But also, there's a button--
Buy.
And that's what we call
a call to action.
I'm not just sharing this with
my friends, I'm also telling
them, hey, you should
buy this thing.
You should do something with
this thing, because I think
that this thing is really
important for you.
And what happens when I share
this with my friends?
They receive a notification
across all the Google
properties.
And in this example, we have
YouTube, we have Google Drive,
we have Google Search.
But this will surface also
on Gmail, G+, and so on.
And if they have the Google+ app
installed on their mobile
device, they will receive a
notification on their mobile
device as well.
So this is me receiving
the notification.
I'm telling myself to
buy this thing.
When I open it, this is how
the Share box is rendered.
And what happens when
I click Buy?
You remember when we said deep
linking, putting people,
users, in the context where
we want them to be?
They not only see the object
that I'm sharing.
Adding to cart, buying us a
gift, is one tap away from
them at this point.
They just need to tap on the
green or blue button, and they
will perform the action that
we wanted them to perform.
Notify the Google+ properties,
drive back to your app.
XIANGTIAN DAI: To share from
your app, the first thing to
do is to get the GPPShareBuilder
object.
And you get this object by
calling the shareDialog method
on the GPPShare instance.
This GPPShareBuilder object
allows you to set the
parameters for your
share dialog.
One of the parameters you can
set is the PrefillText, which
allows you, as the developer,
to prepopulate text for the
shareDialog, so the
user does not have
to start from scratch.
You can also set
a URL to share.
The shareDialog shows a preview
of the content of this
URL so user knows what
they are sharing.
Now, to make it an interactive
post, you need to call the
method named
setCallToActionButtonWithLabel.
This method adds a Call to
Action button to the post.
A Call to Action button consists
of three parts.
First, a label, which is one of
the predefined texts on our
developer site that best
describes your action.
For example, Bookmark.
Second, a URL, which must be
on the same domain as the
content URL.
And then lastly, an optional
deepLinkID.
The deepLinkID is a string
understood by your app that
navigates into a particular
view of your app.
This is so that when a user
taps on the Call to Action
button, they are taken directly
into the right place
inside of your app.
If your app is not installed,
the user will be prompted for
it to download and
install your app.
And then they are taken directly
into the right place
inside your app.
Deep linking is cross-platform.
In order to make the interactive
post shared from
your iOS app, handled by your
Android app, and vice versa,
make sure that your OAuth2
clients, or your both iOS and
Android apps in the Google
APIs Console,
are in the same project.
And also make sure that
both clients have
deep linking enabled.
And finally, call the
[? share ?] method on this
GPPShareBuilder instance, and
share dialog will be displayed
to the user.
SILVANO LUCIANI: So after the
active sharing that you've
seen with interactive posts--
users want to share something
with their friends--
we go to passive sharing,
app activities.
And I will use Flixter, which
is another of our partners.
And they were in the
Sandbox today.
If you know Flixter, it's a
community where users can
share reviews and ratings and
movies, and they can also
invite each other to
go watch a movie
somewhere at some time.
So an app activity, it's
something that the app is
writing to Google on behalf
of the users.
The user gave consent
to the app when they
signed in to Google.
And this time, we will focus
on a different part of the
consent dialogue.
As you can see, it's showing
us which type of activities
Flixter wants to write.
And it's asking us, who do you
want to be able to view these
activities on Google?
And again, we can choose
all our circles.
We can choose some
of our circles.
As a top-level option, we can
choose to keep it private.
There are some things that we
want to keep it private, and
we don't want to share
with anyone or be
visible to anyone else.
We can do it right here.
To show what app activities are
about, we have an example
of a movie on Flixter.
And from here, there are two
things that could trigger an
app activity to be written.
The first one is, I can say that
I want to see this movie.
That will trigger
a Want activity.
Or I can add the rating
for that movie.
And that will trigger
a Review activity.
I mentioned two different
types--
Want and Review.
We have 10 different types.
As you can see, some
are more generic.
Some are more specific.
If you have a compelling use
case that are not in this
list, please let us know, and we
will consider if it's worth
implementing your use case.
So what happens after Flixter
has written an app activity?
Well, the first place where
we started surfacing app
activities is the profile.
So as you can see, there's a
list of things that I did on
Flixter, movies that I want to
see, movies that I review.
This is visible to all the
people coming to my profile
that I selected in the
consent dialog.
And as you can see, I can check
to whom these activities
are currently visible.
What if I change my mind?
I can choose to go back and edit
the circles again, making
this wider or smaller.
What happens if there's a
specific activity that I want
to share with more people?
I can do it from here.
I can actually do many
different things.
I can delete the activity, I
can report the activity as
spam if I don't like what
the app is doing.
But if the press the button in
the middle, at this point I
can share it to Google+, with
the public, or with the circle
of my friends that I know
they like to destroy
world with a hammer.
There is another thing that we
started doing and that we
announced a couple of weeks
ago, Which is search
integration.
So we started surfacing
activities from the users in
Google Search.
So if we search on Google for
Flixter, on the right you can
see that we are telling you
which are the most popular
activities on Flixter
by Google users.
And if you click on any of those
activities, they will go
back to the Flixter website.
XIANGTIAN DAI: Before your app
can write app activities, you
need to declare all types of
app activities your app is
about to write before
user signs in.
This is so that user has a
chance to review the list of
app activities.
To do that, I find Actions
property of the GPPSignIn
instance to an array of strings,
each of which is an
app activity type.
Now, to write app activity,
first you need to construct a
Moment object, which represents
app activity.
Assign the type of this Moment
object to be the type of the
app activity, and assign the
target of this Moment object
to be the target of
the app activity--
in our case, a URL.
Please note that we require
certain schema.org microdata
on the content of this URL.
Refer to our developer
doc for more details.
Now, with this Moment object,
it's time to construct our
query object.
We'll construct our
query object to
insert this Moment object.
And this query consists
of three objects.
First, the Moment object that
we just constructed.
Second, a special string, "me,"
which represents the
current user.
And third, a constant for
the default collection.
Now again, execute the query
on the plusService.
And in the completion handler,
you can check whether your app
activity has been successfully
written or not.
SILVANO LUCIANI: So the last
thing, as we mentioned, is
something that we ask you
implement in your developer
policies, sign out, and a
disconnect functionality.
Now, how many of you know
what to sign out means?
I hope everyone.
Sign out means that when the
users are signed into your
app, they get the personalized
experience.
When they are signed
out, they don't.
So you don't show them in the
app any data that you retrieve
from that profile and that is
specific to their profile.
Disconnect is something
different.
It means that the user tried
your app, it worked for
awhile, the love is finished.
They don't want your
app anymore.
They want to delete any link
between your app and their
Google+ account.
So for you, this means that you
also need to delete all
the information that you
obtained from the Google+ API.
Now, there are some important
exceptions to this.
For example, if you need to
keep some information to
comply with laws or regulation,
let's say as a
proof of purchase,
you can do it.
And you can find more details
at developers.googl
e.com/+/policies, all that you
can keep, and all that you
cannot keep.
XIANGTIAN DAI: The GPPSignIn
object already implements the
signOut and Disconnect
methods.
So all you have to do is to call
these methods as needed.
And don't forget to clean
up user data.
Both signOut and Disconnect
methods remove user
credentials from memory
and from keychain.
However, there's a difference
between these two methods.
SignOut removes user
credentials
for the current device.
On the other hand, Disconnect
revokes user credentials for
the user connecting to the
app across all devices.
If you want to know whether
disconnect succeeds or not,
implement the optional method in
GPPSignInDelegate protocol
called didDisconnectWithError.
And you can check the
results there.
SILVANO LUCIANI: So to conclude,
why do you want to,
when you go out from this
room, start integrating
Google+ in your iOS
app immediately?
Because of all of
these points.
It's easy.
The integration is very
easy when you use
the Google+ iOS SDK.
You get the login from
a trusted provider.
You get Profile and Social
Graph access.
And also, you get to drive
adoption and engagement using
interactive posts, and you get
re-engagement using app
activities.
You've seen some examples.
You've seen all of those
partners are being very
successful with their
integration, and they're
improving their apps and the
experience for their users.
So go out and try it out.
And thanks for coming.
XIANGTIAN DAI: Thank you.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Now, if you
have any questions, please use
the two mics.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for the talk.
I just have a quick question
about analytics on the
interactive posts.
I was wondering if there's a way
that you can track who is
making the interactive posts
and then which users are
clicking on those posts, as a
way to be able to identify
users and then ultimately
influencers and people who are
easily influenced.
SILVANO LUCIANI: So you can
get aggregate data.
There's no way of tracking who
is sharing, because it's an
[? added ?]
Share box.
So everything that's happening
inside the Google + iOS app.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So right.
It's outside the scope
of being able to
identify to a user.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Yeah.
But you can get aggregate data
on how your interactive posts
are performing.
And if you have different
platforms, Android Web and
iOS, you can see which platform
is working best, and
things like that.
AUDIENCE: I've got a question
regarding the storage of the
identity in the keychain.
Sometimes, I found on several
apps, that you need to store a
different type of security.
Like, always available,
only when
devices is first unlocked.
Can you comment a little
bit on that one
and how it will work?
Especially in the case when
you have, let's say, two
iPhone devices that are using
Google Sign-In, and they're
trying to exchange information
with the app is backgrounded.
XIANGTIAN DAI: Yes.
Actually, when user successfully
signed in, we
store the user's credential in
the private keychain, it's
actually private to your app.
So each app will hold its own
storage of user's credentials.
So we don't have sharing
between apps.
AUDIENCE: OK.
But it's more regardless to
there's an attribute for that
keychain [? attribute ?]
that's been written.
So if my application is
backgrounded, and it's waking
up by a service like Bluetooth
[? profile ?] connection, I
won't be able to get
the credential.
So that will bubble up errors.
So I was wondering if there
is a solution for that.
XIANGTIAN DAI: Well, if we
cannot get the keychain, and
you try to authenticate,
we'll always invoke the
authentication flow again.
It's just an optional
optimization thing, that we
try to save you the time by
giving them the choice not to
type the password again.
Actually, giving you, as
developer, choice to use this
functionality.
So if it's not available, then,
well, we just don't have
this functionality, and users
have to sign in again.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a question about the
Google Disconnect and the
deleting of data that you've
gathered from their profile.
So here's the hypothetical
scenario.
Say I've implemented a sign-in
where I've used some of the
Google+ profile information to
assist a registration to an
account of my own, of
my application.
And say I pull up an email
address, and I've gotten
permission to gather email
address and then have asked
somebody to enter in their own
password to create their own
account on my application.
Now, if somebody then
disconnects the app, and I
have gathered that email
information to seed my
registration, must I also delete
that email address?
Or does that email address
become my own data?
SILVANO LUCIANI: So if you
got the address from the
Google+ API, yeah.
Unless there's some law or
regulation that's asking you
to keep the email address for
any reason, then the answer is
yes, from the Google+ API.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SILVANO LUCIANI: Oh, OK.
Maybe I'm wrong.
AUDIENCE: Hi--
SILVANO LUCIANI: But that's
a different API.
AUDIENCE: If you presented a
form for the user, and you
pre-filled it, and they have
entered that, then they're
giving that information
to you.
So that's separate, necessarily,
from the
information that's
coming back.
So that's going to be covered
by your own terms.
So you wouldn't necessarily
have to
delete that stuff, then.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Yeah.
So it's another thing.
It's another way of getting the
email address, which is
using another scope,
userinfo.email.
In that case, it doesn't come
from the Google+ API, so you
can keep it.
AUDIENCE: Oh, if I added it
as one of the scope--
SILVANO LUCIANI: Yeah.
It's an additional scope, and
it will be shown in the
consent dialog.
So you would see an additional
line, which would say, this
app wants to know your
email address.
AUDIENCE: OK.
SILVANO LUCIANI: And that will
be shown to the user.
AUDIENCE: Right.
OK.
Thank you.
SILVANO LUCIANI: I
think that's it.
Thanks.
XIANGTIAN DAI: Thank you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]